[Música]
el presidente de Ecuador Guillermo lasso
se enfrenta a un juicio político Este
martes un proceso iniciado por la
oposición que lo acusa de malversación
de fondos públicos y que cuenta con
mayoría en el congreso ampliamos desde
quito
la canciller de Perú Ana Cecilia gervasi
arremetió contra los presidentes de
México y Colombia por sus declaraciones
en contra del gobierno de Dina boluarte
en televisión declaró que la actitud de
estos presidentes va contra la
convivencia democrática en la región
y en un reporte sumamente crítico con el
FBI el fiscal especial John Durham
concluye que las autoridades no tenían
evidencia real para lanzar una
investigación sobre la presunta
complicidad de la campaña de Donald
Trump en 2016 con Rusia El Magnate
reaccionó asegurando que los
responsables deben pagar un alto precio
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos hoy en Quito
la capital de Ecuador en donde Este
martes dará comienzo el juicio político
contra el presidente Guillermo lasso
según la oposición lasso habría
incurrido en presunta malversación al no
haber hecho nada ante las presuntas
irregularidades en un contrato firmado
por la empresa Estatal flota petrolera
del Ecuador y la firma privada amazonas
tanker de las que según la oposición la
sostenía conocimiento ahora esta
oposición necesitan 92 votos a favor
cuatro más de los obtenidos en los pasos
anteriores de este proceso para aprobar
la destitución de lasso anteriormente
nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega nos
contaba cómo va a ser el inicio de este
proceso
bueno en la sesión parlamentaria
comienza a partir de las diez de la
mañana y cada interpelante participará
contará con un tiempo de dos horas para
presentar así sus pruebas lo hará en
principio La asambleísta acusadora
Viviana veloz que representa la fracción
parlamentaria de unes a fin al
expresidente Rafael Correa y De igual
forma también lo hará el asambleísta
Esteban Torres representante de la
bancada parlamentaria del partido social
cristiano antiguos coidiarios de el
presidente de la república ellos
contarán con dos horas y posteriormente
Entonces será la llegada al presidente
de la república que él oraba a partir de
las Trece horas donde el presidente de
la república asistirá para defenderse de
estas acusaciones de peculado algunos
datos luego de proseguir lo que será el
debate parlamentario tanto de las
acusaciones como la defensa del
presidente de la república se abre el
debate serán hasta siete horas de
presentación de pruebas y defensas hasta
que se abra así el debate parlamentario
posteriormente a esto entonces cada
asambleísta de 137 parlamentarios
asistentes a el pleno de la asamblea
nacional contará de diez minutos para
presentar así sus razonamientos nueva
polémica entre Perú y los presidentes de
México Andrés Manuel López Obrador y de
Colombia Gustavo Petro tras varias
declaraciones de ambos mandatarios
criticando al gobierno de Dina boluarte
la canciller peruana Ana Cecilia gervasi
declaró en televisión que la actitud de
estos presidentes va contra la
convivencia democrática en la región
aseguró además que la decisión de amlo
de no entregarle a Perú la presidencia
pro tempore de la alianza del Pacífico
es una muestra de su negligencia en
política exterior el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores del Perú expresa
su más categórico rechazo a la recientes
y reiteradas declaraciones injerencistas
y responsables e ideologizadas de los
señores Petro de Colombia y López de
México
insiste en el desconocer El golpe de
estado perpetrado por el expresidente
Pedro Castillo El Siete de diciembre de
2022 y la sucesión legítima y
constitucional de la señora presidenta
de la República Dina boluarte zegarra
que ha sido reconocida ampliamente por
la comunidad internacional
nos vamos ahora hasta Colombia en donde
el proceso de negociación entre el
gobierno y la guerrilla del eln sufrió
otro revés el lunes el jefe negociador
del ejército de liberación nacional
alias Paulo Beltrán afirmó en un vídeo
desde la Habana la capital de Cuba que
el diálogo de paz se encuentra en pausa
por la crisis que según la guerrilla
generó el presidente Gustavo Petro el
pasado viernes ante almirantes y
generales Petro puso en duda el
verdadero liderazgo de los comandantes
del eln y aseveró que la razón de ser de
algunos frentes son las economías
ilícitas
y en Estados Unidos El
concluyó que el FBI y el departamento de
Justicia estadounidenses no debieron
haber lanzado una investigación sobre
presunta vinculación entre la campaña
presidencial de Donald Trump y Rusia en
el año 2016 según el reporte de 300
páginas de Durham nombrado en 2019 por
el fiscal general del gobierno del
propio Trump se empleó información de
inteligencia no corroborada sin procesar
ni analizar nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos entregó
más temprano los detalles el consejero
especial John dollman asignado durante
la administración de Donald Trump para
investigar la pesquisa que hizo en su
momento el FBI sobre los posibles
vínculos de la campaña de Donald Trump y
Rusia en la carrera presidencial del
2016 publicó un reporte después de
cuatro años de investigación en este
concluyó que el FBI Nunca debió haber
iniciado una investigación completa
sobre las conexiones entre la campaña de
Trump y Rusia durante las elecciones del
2016 concretamente investigó el manejo
que el FBI le dio al expediente es tío
las filtraciones de información
clasificada sobre los contactos de Trump
y Rusia y la posible Mala conducta de la
Cia con respecto a su análisis de la
intromisión rusa entre otros temas en su
reporte de 300 páginas reveló que el FBI
usó inteligencia cruda no analizada y no
corroborada para iniciar la
investigación y usó un estándar
diferente al considerar las
preocupaciones sobre la supuesta
interferencia electoral con respecto a
la campaña de hillary Clinton sin
embargo no recomendó ningún cargo nuevo
contra algún individuo al respecto el
expresidente Donald Trump reaccionó en
su red social diciendo que el público
americano había sido engañado como lo
está haciendo actualmente por su parte
el congresista republicano Jim Jordan
quien se desempeña como presidente del
comité judicial de la cámara de
representantes anunció que se comunicó
con el departamento de justicia para que
dureham testifique la próxima semana en
el congreso
el Primer Ministro canadiense Justin
trudó viajó hasta el estado de Alberta
en una visita los operarios que luchan
desde hace semanas contra los fuegos
incontrolados el domingo en la tarde 89
fuegos estaban todavía activos 25 de
ellos fuera de control y 19.000 personas
habían sido evacuadas se espera que al
menos durante 10 días no llueva en la
región la emergencia además por estos
incendios llevó a una reducción en la
producción de petróleo en esta zona en
un equivalente al 3,7% de la producción
nacional una producción que ya ha sido
parcialmente reactivada
y desde la frontera Sur estadounidense
con México se reporta cierta calma y un
fuerte descenso en la entrada irregular
de migrantes desde el final del título
42 según datos del departamento de
seguridad nacional estadounidense estos
cruces se han reducido en un 50% con
cerca de 5000 pases diarios pese a ello
las autoridades de la Unión Americana
aseguran haber deportado a miles de
personas hacia 10 países incluidos
México Colombia o Perú
Durante los últimos tres días hemos
visto una disminución de aproximadamente
el 50% en los encuentros En comparación
con los días previos al final del título
42 sin embargo Todavía es temprano y
somos conscientes de que Los
contrabandistas seguirán buscando formas
de aprovechar el cambio en las políticas
fronterizas y es importante señalar que
si bien el título 42 ha terminado las
condiciones que están causando la
migración hemisférica a niveles sin
precedentes no ha cambiado continuamos
viendo más personas desplazadas en el
hemisferio que en décadas pero estamos
trabajando en estrecha colaboración con
nuestros socios para abordar estos
movimientos al proporcionar vías legales
proteger a los migrantes vulnerables y
hacer cumplir sus propias fronteras
en México se celebró este lunes el día
de los maestros en el estado de Chiapas
unos 2000 profesores de la coordinadora
nacional de trabajadores de la educación
salieron a las calles de Tuxtla
Gutiérrez para reiterar sus demandas
laborales entre ellas mejores salarios
allí marcharon hacia el Zócalo de la
urbe unas marchas que se han repetido en
varias ciudades del país
y cerramos en la ciudad brasileña de
Santos donde abrió sus puertas el
mausoleo conmemorativo de Rey el rey
Pelé el lugar empieza a recibir a los
fanáticos del tres veces campeón del
mundo con la canarinha el espacio cuenta
con 200 metros cuadrados suelo en césped
sintético y un techo azulado sobre la
tumba que es dorada y tiene imágenes de
los momentos más importantes de la
carrera de Pelé que murió a los 82 años
el 29 de diciembre de 2022
con estas imágenes Nos despedimos sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]